hello I'm Gavin I'm done where'd the
slow-mo go yeah I've got some battery to
it you know the ones from like
calculators and things like yep yep and
you know how much I hate warnings and
you bloody aim I do yeah it's a warning
keep out of reach of children or already
fail that one yet through risk of injury
due to fire explosion do not expose the
fire or high temperatures ah can I hide
in the house while you do it
I'll frame up and like it okay I'll just
sit behind I think yeah these are
lithium double-a yeah a normal alkaline
double-a you know what happens when you
burn it it kind of just goes and catches
on fire just stays right it this does
not stay where it is passes wind that
one explode yeah sweet like a little jet
engine so we've got some calculate
batches here pocket cut thing Sean I
feel gave me that Leatherman yeah yep
I'll never forget it
the clamshell package within clamshell
packaging you can't get to them they're
sealed within the seal path honestly I
don't think this will be the loudest I'm
making this video hat maybe the
dangerous explosions because what's the
point in this packaging go ah don't do
that kid Oh any of this video alright
what should we start with it start with
the smallest one we get some focus on
that oh yeah Keaney
Oh
cool
so loud
[Music]
I don't know when to the moon yeah we're
really high they just pop the top stuff
make sure you get your face right Debbie
yeah it's something my life of
everything
I assume the air the metal shell top
would really hurt fit you in the gob you
won't be able to calculate how fast it's
actually moving yeah about absolutely
rapid just telling the audience to
teller yeah I mean it's a just leave the
bottom get behind me stop it snaps I get
off all right so we try the next size up
these are the slightly wider that is
this dinner
[Music]
we
you
went pretty high that I'm going to have
my face mark yeah they all seem to
follow the same sort of back to the left
trajectory their back until the old JFK
so now we'll move on to the most
dangerous you're going to negative local
sound move away in - seeing and running
tricular coming in account yeah little
ones you want it so this is a double a
lithium
other supreme puffs of smoke
well applause what's a jet taking on has
been ready plane but it went behind the
propane said it what's on this one
because we've written to find the back
pieces hopefully you can catch the [__]
you going either way
and once you go any less later no
nothing to smaller things right we will
get here
oh we need be
that's always a need ah ha ha of course
of thing
we
lovely Jerry that one cleanliness is
lovely
oh my god you're cooling something cool
yeah pretty sure I heard some hit the
house yeah I start them in hit the wall
when I was in there no one look examine
Oh all this color just and burn off this
video not sponsored by E and F all those
escalated quite nicely yeah something
I've noticed is a the other rocketed off
yeah they've actually got four holes in
the back I think that's just to stop
them actually exploding exploding I
think that's for a later on yeah in a
fail-safe on the battery to release the
pressure but only when I kept coming out
into jet yeah they always come out of
there's four little holes here and
otherwise I think they just sort of
actually explode all the [__] but
instead they sort of shoot off and
retain their shape now I'm glad we
didn't seal up the the fail holes Wow I
mean how you're going to feel that
really glue I think cement cement yes
brilliant so is that the colour if
there's a house fire or something they
don't want them actually exploding the
kitchen drawer I can let the old man
draw just blow up my keys and useless
items no honestly didn't see that I love
it this is notice that yeah nine I said
before that's all right yeah what Tim oh
you didn't mention it once I felt it
there you go I thought you just saw them
so right and I never learn something can
be outro before there was but that was
it well hopefully you enjoyed that video
and you also loved the battery tab jet
holes
feel free to follow us on Twitter
subscribe to the second channel this
one's more important you should ascribe
for that one first if you have it and
much sweet you know what I haven't
mentioned in a while but if Dad sees you
wearing one of these yeah he will buy
you a drink and is still in effect and
always will be as long as we are in this
civil partnership civil partnerships I
mean just friends
but with quick